[Music]  in the car  we're all going now you I said we're all  going  you do want thing to do housing survival  6040  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  you're no war allow me to reintroduce  myself my name is home there's two of  them and two billion dollars worth of us  is the three of us don't work together  themes of people will die your sister is  one of the toughest baddest most capable  women I've ever encountered know what I  got a girl let's see what you do you  think I'm stupid  of course I think you're stupid  never claimed to have wings on  [Music]  we're gonna need cars and guns oh I can  handle that part I'm sorry to bring this  here mama  Luke this is your home don't let cool  you're gonna get one style more an ass  whoopee Superman  there comes a Crips about that my hand  ever keeps hot  in a fire oh this is not good we're  going for a ride  movie directors on my Island mother  allow me to reintroduce myself my name  is  [Music]  you  you